[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for The Developer Show.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Nvidia TensorRT is a library
that optimizes deep learning
models for inference and
creates a runtime for deployment
on GPUs in production
environments.
TensorRT and TensorFlow are
integrated with TensorFlow 1.7.
In our tests, we found
that ResNet-50 performed
eight times faster,
under seven milliseconds
latency, with the
TensorFlow-TensorRT integration
using Nvidia Volta
tensor cores, as compared
with running TensorFlow only.
For graphs and code,
check out the post.
Android Studio 3.1 is
now available to download
in the stable release channel.
The focus areas for
this release are
around product quality and
app development productivity.
In addition to many
underlying quality changes,
we added several new features
into Android Studio 3.1 that
you should take a
look at integrating
into your development flow,
including a C++ Performance
Profiler, better code editor
support to aid in your SQL
table and query
creation statements,
and better Lint support
for your Kotlin code.
Details and screenshots
are on the post.
The Wear OS developer
preview is now available,
bringing Android PE platform
features to wearables.
Included are the
Dark UI system theme,
and restriction related to
non-SDK methods and fields.
Install instructions
are on the post.
Stackdriver Profiler
is now available.
It lets you profile and explore
how your code actually executes
in production to
optimize performance
and reduce cost of computation.
Head on over to the
post to learn more
about the Stackdriver
application performance
management toolkit,
including integrations
between Stackdriver Debugger and
GitHub Enterprise and GitLab.
You can use Cloud Text-to-Speech
for high-quality text-to-speech
synthesis that produces
natural-sounding speech.
It lets you choose from 32
different voices from 12
languages and variants,
correctly pronounces
complex texts such as names,
dates, times, and addresses,
and allows you to
customize pitch,
speaking rate, and volume gain.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Kubernetes Engine
Private Clusters
is now available in beta.
With it, you can deploy
clusters privately
as part of the Google
virtual private cloud.
Your cluster's
nodes can then only
be accessed from
within the trusted VPC.
Getting started instructions
are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CREW: Rolling.
All right, DS 106 take 1, mar.
Up.